Jay Ferrel back on here unsane in
theaters now directed by Steven
Soderbergh starring Claire Foy who plays
the Queen and the Queen right now on
Netflix and then you search a farragut
to see is a phenomenal actress actor
what do they call them now you can't say
that's being yeah there we go
she's a thespian yeah let's take it back
to the fifteen hundreds yes you know
it's good to man this I mean this role I
mean it's it's a dramatic it's a
dramatic side however it was just cool
for subtle Berg to you know actually
call me up and say listen yeah I do have
this part and I know you have a dramatic
side and I'm gonna put that out to the
world so are you willing to do this say
no to you so your phone rings and it's
Steven Soderbergh yeah man
dude I he told me that Matt Damon um a
long time ago they won a set and was
some movie and Matt Damon show to him um
the Denzel vs Will Smith thing I did
back 2010 and then he said Wow and he
was a fan since then that's how he does
wow wow that's amazing
and so now you you know subtle Berg - we
have met wow that's good he does this I
love sort of brace such a genius man
he's such a genius and the fact that he
did shoot this on an iPhone it just lets
you know you ain't got no excuse if you
shoot your shot right shoot my bow pick
on a Samsung not that not that who's
gonna play me I mean I guess I'll play
me be some shitty roommate mild type
stuff but you know I figured man Samsung
man yeah I'm gonna be I'm gonna be the
first one to shoot move in the Samsung
laws don't do it on a blackberry if
you're doing a blackberry sucking life I
used to have a blackberry I found
somebody with Lauren come on I was like
yo just like that's a fossil right there
in your pocket like dog nobody uses
those anymore
they were snow up to eight tracks doing
I mean each racks isn't Polaroid film
it's more like big record players they
just have
that reminds me of I'm gonna get you
sucker member when you're walking around
with the big 78 for the music it's like
it's just walking around for the theme
music oh that's my goodness that's uh oh
snap you know what okay it's what I want
to savor it go for it
me and my homeboy is this some real dope
y'all ready yes all right so we were
downstairs at my crew we're at my crib
my career has two floors oh great
for now cuz hopefully one day we'll have
more yeah I'll be I'll be Jamie Foxx
white famous real um and we sitting down
we had baked wings right we sitting
there chilling there you know drink and
then we start playing classical music
and then we have conversations about
WorldStarHipHop do you know how dope
that is to be a black man eating baked
wings listening to classical music
like what like Beethoven your classical
musical SoundCloud and started playing
and then we sitting eating chickens at
yeah bro you good yeah I'm good
it was it was like one of the realest we
got to do a show about that we're gonna
I'm crap this all in my head right now
you have can you can you grab any music
see if we can figure out so Jay Pharoah
could possibly recreate this is it your
crib is I'm a career bottom floor -
bottom floor bottom floor bottom floor
we got love big wings I just did
shout-out to them so y'all better send
me I pay I put y'all through college I
ordered too much I put I put their kids
through college I were there's so much
big wing so yeah I'm eating big wings we
playing classical music you know I mean
just talking about you know black stuff
it was dope
like what give me ferns cardi B all
right yes a little can I say beware go
for okay little [ __ ]
you can't f with me if you want to these
expensive these is rare but on this
bloody show you like your man you think
I'll set a card B gonna stay together
yeah maybe dog yeah I'm trying to smash
for her like it was it was it was so
dope
smashing means having intercourse you
all okay I know you got a scientific
term site intercourse intercourse I
can't say that could be like Richard
Pryor opiate if that is true gotta say
and of course that's what I got to say I
gotta say cuz I can't say Evan even if I
want to Rick I can't write I just
thought that that might be now the the
serious thespian side of Jay Pharoah
that's true your if you are rebranding
sir that is true you know what I'm
saying that is true and of course it
sounded better the second time it did
yeah like you understand it's one more
time one more time
time's a charm yeah but the second time
was a charm but it's gonna be a charm
okay intercourse yeah absolutely
so Soderbergh called you on the phone
and then you do this this film how has
it been received by people who've known
you for years and that they come up and
saved we don't even know who you are
anymore
a lot of I've only heard I've only heard
great reviews right I've only heard and
read great reviews that's I've only
heard good things read great reviews
yeah but they're saying man this is kind
of cool that Jays branching off and it
is because it's like he's a real actor
we didn't know he can act I was like
work you know I gonna act I've been on
television for how many years now eight
you know I can act they're like no but
you're so good in this I'm like yeah man
so I guess I guess this is just opening
up a lane for more of those type of
dramatic roles and you know I still do
comedic roles too so it's just fun to
get to do this because it is a side that
folks haven't seen before and I've been
dramatic acting since I was 8
I've been dramatic acting long I've been
doing comedy no one I started drawing
when I was 8
what was your first one my first move my
movie my first let bother if you're in
movies at 800 no no no no movies at 8 so
Jay Ferrel child star was playing and
what what were you doing I was mice and
Mozart that's right I was one of the
I was nice and Mozart that was my first
play I remember that because I was I was
a mouse and I was chunky too I was a
little chunky kid you know cuz you know
I'm black and black folks we got nice
butts so mine I had a had a Kim
Kardashian Nicki Minaj thing happening
so you could identify me through the
mouth she blazed one with a little fatty
oh that's that's Jared yeah oh I hate
saying my government name it sucks
Jarrod Jarrod Jarrod yeah so you're
Jared Farrell my name is Jared arrow hmm
yeah okay yeah thanks mom I don't know
oh okay so back to the questions get
back let's get back on task so you were
on mice and mowed mice and Mozart and I
played and then I just continued with
school plays did community theater I was
wowed while in a hairy man I was
Charlotte and Charlotte's Web I was in
Harriet the Spy with the her all players
I switched over when I did a high school
I did um your grand old flag I was Jake
the jerk I did Damn Yankees I was mr.
Applegate I did Oliver Twist I was I was
on I was Bill Sikes I was Bill Sikes
yeah man this is I'm just telling you
man
this is this is deep-rooted but it did
not just start it and come out the blue
I've been doing this for years just the
first time by shot on a phone
shot an iPhone 7 so unchanged in
theaters new you right now I'm gonna
take a break we'll come back I know
you're fired up about the Rams
yeah getting Brandon cooks oh yes and
then I saw the Pats right yes yes hey
bro look I'm a Rams fan brother I know
that not I'm sad you legit and Jared
Goff is uh and Jared Goff is doping so
in a go ahead okay Sean McVeigh we'll
take out little take a break we'll come
back with Jay Pharoah and then I saw
that video that you did on for Vanity
Fair where you had to all these great
imitations I want to yeah shoot shoot
you some sports questions through it and
random guys who you imitate okay and
mash it all together and you have no
idea what I'm about to ask I have no
idea but that'll be downright unsafe
a pharaoh package 66
[Music]
is this from Trading Places frozen
concentrated orange juice also Jay
Pharoah here on the Richardson show
Laird speaks now you are originally from
where where are you originally
Chesapeake Virginia shout out the
Greenbrier yeah that's right so isn't
that Redskins territory I mean it could
you could say it could be man but they
just bandwagons they just people in
Virginia just hop one to the DC they try
to claim it really I'll never Redskins
fan I was like man forget the risk I
wanna be somebody I wanna do something
different okay so I was the st. Louis
Rams fan when I was back in when I
started watching football like 99 oh so
you're talking greatest show on turf I'm
Yaak Warner Isaac Bruce yeah man the
friggin the the dream the dream team
squad man right and then and then you
know for a few years after they lost to
the Patriots mmm-hmm they had a little
low you know they had a dip but now
they're back they're stronger than ever
man and dude Sean McVeigh jizz I he's
got that I man and how was he 31 31
he's like one year older than me and
he's got way more money I was let's Rob
[Laughter]
I'm just trying to get you attention man
so I get season tickets I'm trying to
I'm trying to be at every game well he
just he just might tell to if over there
just reoptimize I got my PSL fix I'm
glad to get a new stadium man because
that one that did look dad dad looked it
was it was it was trashed that Stadium
that Stadium that Stadium was bad I'll
hear another word for it looked like a
Coliseum
yes distinguished you said to ancient
crumbling you're early
well they're doing some renovations to
it but just by the time for the
renovations they'll build this a new
stage yeah I guess they feel like rich I
feel like what they wanted to do
like let's see how they're gonna do this
year and if they do if they make it to
the playoffs
we'll give them a budget yeah and me
it's kind of like Black Panther did with
Forest Whitaker and his I they fixed it
[Music]
took some money that took about 40 mil
to do that CGI on Forest Whitaker's on
Quivers sometimes like you ever seen it
quiver before like it winks at you like
it but it winks unintentionally like in
real life story the true story after the
Super Bowl in New York City between the
Seahawks and the Broncos Oh flying back
to Los Angeles was a snow a snow storm
hit oh and I was in the lounge if you
will with him and his wife and me and
the Joel McHale life how was that it was
it was dicey yeah I wouldn't stay at him
I was past me - hey for us what up man
you don't want to be disrespectful if
you know which way I never I never
thought I would be standing in line for
those you know square cheddar cubes and
and soup and crackers with Forest
Whitaker it's a very thought I'd be you
know standing there for that did he get
the pepper jack I think you I think he
went pepper Jesus speaks oh I look great
see he's still he's still in the
community a lot about you to cheese you
take um I've got some got some sports
questions for that I'd like you to
answer as other individuals if you were
fine with yeah yeah goats Jay Pharoah
here I'd like to ask Jay Z to what
advice to give June Carlos Stanton after
striking out five times in his home
debut and getting booed by Yankee fans
as he was just a CEO I mean yeah you
know stick it out yeah baby yeah you
know you gotta you know you gotta you
gotta fail to succeed so you
maybe he gonna come back as a beast oh
that's my advice for him Kevin Hart
why didn't security let you onto the
Philadelphia Eagles podium Apple listen
listen rich first of all the haters rich
that's thing the haters and they
couldn't see me but they would have saw
me then they would have known who I was
and I would have been right up there
with the Philadelphia Eagles bringing
the good times and ye because you know
celebrate celebration time you know me
up there I just want to say freedom free
McMeel that's what I want to say free
Meek Mill mink Mill's never come to one
of my concerts doesn't matter still
Philadelphia BAM I say free meek and I
say the next time I need you all to know
who I am cuz I'm the biggest star on a
freakin planet like it's me in a rock
that's it
this is me in a rock rich that's it
nobody else credible I'm about to sell
out the solar system BAM I'm gonna do
and the rock says I'm just playing good
Rock The Rock says jabroni you see rich
Rich Eisen the rock the Brahma bull
sitting here you're talking about Kevin
Hart why did he get why did he get IX
courted away from the Philadelphia
Eagles that's because he was drunk rich
he was drunk rich the rock doesn't drink
the rock you know what the rock does the
rock has a juice but rock has a Clint
because every day at 2:00 p.m. I said
2:00 p.m. for rock Johnson deuce that's
what he does
what does he walk around his house and
be like but the way Johnson told you to
pick up the toys you didn't pick up the
toys now the Wayne Johnson it's putting
you on a punishment but the Wayne
Johnson is not gonna lay the smackdown
because the Wayne Johnson doesn't want
to get sued by the government sued by
somebody calling the government then you
want something happened when they take
away your child you know baby you know
another good one for you I'd like to ask
Jason Statham Oh what do you think about
the NFL's new targeting rules to make
the game safer let's see here and the
game of football you have to be really
really rough and if you're rough that's
when you get a good show now if you're
not rough then it's gonna be a little
pansy so what thing they shouldn't do it
cuz I don't like pansies I hate pansies
you know policies people have beat up in
my films I beat them up all the time and
you know what I do I've come finish with
them I sit on top of their bodies and I
have sex with my girl Stephen H Smith
what do you think about the n-c-double-a
making billions from TV contracts that
don't pay the players I think that's
totally blasphemous and it's incredulous
I can't believe that they allow it not
to happen it's totally ridiculous
inconspicuous Ludacris shut your mouth
that's what it is I don't understand
what it is you know take that Rwanda bag
Ludacris got the track to make you booty
go clap reminder back that's what I
think about that but they not let's talk
about somebody let's talk about Colin
Kaepernick that's what we need to do
let's talk about Colin Kaepernick
because I've said it before
I feel like Colin Kaepernick gets more
attention not being a football player
than he does beautiful ball play now
tell me what that's about
tell me what that's about rich you'll
set that man down you talk to him you
tell him they get back on the field
I got one last one for you let's do it
okay
what advice would is it Michael kind
hugger would fit got two more if you
okay this is fun what advice would
Denzel Washington give to Odell Beckham
right now that's right he's going to uh
there were teams Odell Beckham cousin
John he's only well he's not a giant
snow he was talking about the RAM right
it wasn't your time at the RAM yeah I
say you should come to LA that's what I
say
in New York New York Giants New York is
good but they got rats they got a whole
bunch of homeless people and it's cold
as hell that's right so bring your acid
or west coast that's what I say mm-hmm
my brother Odell Beckham and get a new
haircut that's what I say standing
around here looking like one of the
Muppets from Sesame Street how's that
possible he looks like a muppet on
Sesame Street hmm that's what you call
double entendre he's dope he's cool I
met about I think I met her with Jamie
Foxx like not too long ago it nevermind
no oh is there something that I should
know about that no no you was just you
know he was real spry that's all I'm
saying okay last one is how would Barack
Obama assess the new catch rule in the
NFL where you basically all you need is
two feet down and possession of the
football
you don't have to survive the ground
anymore ah well if we're gonna go back
to that then I believe what we need to
do is take it back to rugby rules and
when I say rugby rules I mean back in
the 1920s when nobody had on hardly any
equipment that's why people sounded the
way they did because when you get hit in
your head that many times without any
protection you end up sounding kind of
like Bobby Brown did when he was high as
hell that's that's what you sound like
and that's what I'm gonna say and I
believe people should stop being punks
that's what I believe let them play no
let him do it
and
at the end of the day you know don't
call me about the country because I
don't it's over anyone pick one oh you
all asked for this I didn't ask for it I
told you I warned you i sat there and I
told you I said get your asses up and
get out and vote nobody and now look
what we got somebody who looks like the
Sun off the Teletubbies and take you
wakey dipsy laa-laa you are the best man
you are supremely talented and I love
you insane
in the Soderbergh movie thank you
brother follow them on Twitter at Jay
Pharaoh welcome here anytime
Thank You Man we'll come back please do
that I will and that's terrible
y'all stop picking on rich let's stop it
he's done that actually my hair listen
rich need to just come on home come on
home it's a terrible it's terrible
that's a tu RI ble turrible that's how
you spill that I said terrible stop rich
come on you go ahead and say the rest of
it all shave your top or what you could
do is you could take some Beijing do
white people get to Beijing I don't know
but if I don't got it huh y'all got the
leg the powder y'all got the y'all got
the salt and pepper shakers right that's
what y'all yeah that's what I put on top
of my pepper just terrible Jay Pharoah
here on the Rich Eisen show we're back
with more in a moment the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience